Brazil's president wasted no time
getting down to business on his first
day in office president Lula da Silva
has made restoring Brazil's leadership
role on the global stage a key priority
he held a host of bilateral meetings
with leaders and diplomats from China to
Europe and Africa to Latin America
I believe President Lula is a regional
leader who will give a strong boost to
Latin America Brazil's absence of the
past few years has been felt Lula's
presence signifies the return of Brazil
to the international stage
former president Jade bolsonaro a
hard-line conservative had little
interest in fostering International ties
especially in his own region
but Lula says that Brazil the world's
fifth largest country and Latin
America's Powerhouse must again become a
major player as it was when he was last
president
Chinese Vice President Juan shishan was
among the first to pay him a visit
although China is Brazil's main trading
partner lulita Silva is concentrating
first on Reviving his long-standing goal
of strengthening Latin American Unity
without leading any country out he has
begun by restoring ties with Venezuela
severed by his predecessor
with President Lula we discussed ways of
incorporating Venezuela into the Latin
American fold as well as the importance
of legitimate elections in Venezuela in
2024 so that they will be really
legitimate with guarantees for All
actors an idea Lula was an influential
figure the last time that many Latin
American countries turned to the left he
believes in strength in numbers although
Latin America is again witnessing a
swing to the left Regional Unity has
always eluded it unlike the European
Union that Unity has always depended on
common ideologies rather than common
interests that's a mistake that Brazil's
new president apparently intends to fix
you see a Newman Al Jazeera Brasilia